Let's talk about how to
handle text in a deep model.
Imagine that you want
to classify a document.
Is it talking about politics,
or business, or science maybe?
You're going to have to look
at the words in that document
to figure that out.
Words are really difficult.
There are lots of them and
most of them you never, ever see.
In fact the ones that you rarely see,
tend to be the most important ones.
If you know that your document contains
duh, you don't know much at all.
But if you know that it
contains retinopathy,
you know that it's probably
a medical document.
Retinopathy appears with
a frequency of 0.0001% in English.
It's even possible that you've never
seen that word yourself before.
For deep learning,
rare events like that are a problem.
We like to have lots of training
examples to learn from.